So the fundamental thing that I learned
from Paul Rosen is to see us as these
amazing omnivores.
This is part of our survival strategy
even more than other other apes.
We are just brilliant omnivores and we
have the Omnivore's dilemma,
which is we've got to be interested in
all kinds of new stuff.
We're not tied to one place we can roam
onto a whole new continent.
So we were interested in stuff,
but stuff has all kinds of toxins and
microbes.
We have to be careful about that stuff.
And so these motives have to be
intention and this is actually an
interesting way to understand the left
right difference.
You have to have both motives,
but if so,
imagine two siblings,
one of whom is set more towards trying
new stuff,
seeking out new stuff,
and the other's a little more fearful
and we're like,
Whoa,
no,
let's,
let's not try that.
That stayed with what's tried and true.
I mean that's Progressive Ism and
conservatives and that's the origins of
it.
And if you look at kids' behavior at the
age of two or three,
it does predict how they'll vote much
later.
Not Hugely,
but there is a clear prediction there.
So,
um,
so disgust is part of a regulatory
system about our engagement with the
world and whether we are just sorta out
there and,
you know,
we,
we seek out variety and diversity.
We think diversity is just a great thing
where whether we want a little more
order structure,
predictability.
I'm conservatives are neater than
progressive's.
If you take photos of their rooms,
um,
you know,
you can actually,
cleanliness and organization,
you can predict how they vote,
um,
discussed.
It turns out what's really cool about
disgust in modern politics is if you
look at all the different things that
we're fighting over,
especially in this country,
our culture war is over,
you know,
going back a few decades,
sex,
drugs,
the flag,
immigration,
all of these things.
Um,
I had to study with my colleagues was
led by Seneca Leyva in which we asked
all these cultural war attitudes of
people and we also had their scores and
the discus scale.
But one of the foundations of morality
is sanctity and purity.
And it relates to discuss what we found
is that if you know,
if you know,
um,
uh,
what people's left,
right?
We're,
how they place themselves in the left
rightscale you can pretty much predict
where they fall on most cultural war
attitudes except for those that load on
or implicate sanctity or purity.
So what I mean his flag burning.
Okay.
Do you think,
you know,
do you think that people should have the
right to burn the American flag or the
country's flag as an expression,
as a political action?
What do you think people could give some
answer on a one to seven scale and
people on the right thing?
You know,
I'm more like this ain't no people in
the left.
Yes.
People are score high on loyalty are
more likely to say no people lower and
say yes.
And that's even taking account of where
they are on the left right dimension.
But here's the cool thing,
um,
it's only if you add in the purity or
sanctity thing that you can really
understand what people are doing because
some people see the flag not as just a
piece of cloth.
They see it as having some innate
essence,
some something sacred about it which
must be protected.
And so,
um,
so this is true even they think of it as
a unifying center.
Exactly.
That's right.
So if there's something sacred,
and this is the,
this is the central piece of my work
around politics and morality is the
psychology of sanctity.
If you hold something sacred,
then your team's circles around it and
it's only those who circle around with
you and sometimes literally circle
around like Muslims at prayer in Mecca,
they literally circle the Kebab.
Circling is a very primitive,
ancient.
It feels right to circle something,
but even if even if you do it
symbolically or you all bow at the same
time that binds you together,
children do that with their mothers when
they,
when they engage in exploratory
behavior,
right where all they use their mother as
a center of the world.
And children differ in the degree to
which they'll move outward from their
mothers.
So they move out until they,
they,
they trip over their,
their uncertainty threshold a neat.
And is it a distance?
Like it's a district?
Yeah.
And so,
so the more exploratory kids who are
lower negative emotion will go out
farther before they come back to their
mother.
So the mother is the center and you know
that that would be associated
symbolically with the idea of the center
as a motherland or potentially as a
father.
That's right.
That makes sense.
So this way that we're.
We're incredibly symbolic creatures.
We're not just out to make as much money
as we can.
Where's this symbolic and social
creatures and this psychology of
sanctity or purity has become really
important,
not just on the right.
It's always been important for
especially religious conservatives were
beginning to see it even on the campus
left.
And this is why I think we see some of
the odd things we see on campus that the
campus must be kept as a sacred and pure
space.
One of the things that really alarms me
about what's happened on campus and last
couple of years is that the older idea
we had that it's a place for contesting
ideas.
It's a,
it's a zone of enormous choice.
People can take what courses they want,
say what they want.
It's kind of a wonderful free for all
with some with norms of respect.
It's now becoming much more of a
religious zone where the perimeter of
the campus is the boundaries and within
it they're almost there.
Blasphemy laws basically,
and I really started noticing this.
When you look at the videos of the
Middlebury,
a protest when Charles Murray spoke at
Middlebury and as everybody knows,
he was shouted down so the students are
chanting and they're chanting in unison
and it seems like a religious revival
meeting and they're swaying and they're
saying they're sacred in a racist,
sexist,
antigay.
Charles Murray go away.
It's like a ritual incantation so that
all the space as safe and it's safe and
not maternal way.
Not yet.
So far all this happening is they're
binding together.
They're moving and you know,
synchronous movement and call and
response.
So it's using a lot of tropes from
religion and religious worship.
But here's the cool thing.
When the administrator,
I forget who it is,
comes on to say,
okay,
we have moved,
we're moving the talk,
and then you hear a couple people
screaming up off campus off campus and
he says to another location on campus
and there's like,
oh no,
no,
because no one had to go to this talk so
everyone could have just stayed home and
the students didn't succeed in shutting
down the venues so they could have
declared victory,
but it's not a full victory unless he is
physically off the campus.
We can't have him speaking on campus
because that defiles us.
That pollutes us.
We must shut that down.
And that's where I started saying,
wow,
this is like full blown psychology of
religion,
Durkheim,
sanctity,
purity,
blast for me.
Uh,
and that I think,
you know,
that doesn't describe most students
that,
that describes this sort of the core,
those who,
who really have their identities wrapped
up in this movie.
Okay.
So,
so we discussed,
I wanted to,
I wanted to ask you a couple of things
about that.
So you know,
the big five research into political
differences basically shows that the
liberals are high in trait,
openness and low in conscientiousness
and the conservatives or the reverse,
but we fragmented conscientiousness into
orderliness and industriousness with the
big five aspect scale and orderliness is
strongly associated with disgust.
So.
Right,
right,
exactly.
It does sound a lot like Freud but it.
But it also isn't accordance with your
observations that conservatives have
neater spaces,
for example.
So,
so now,
and they're meeting start on time.
Yes.
Yeah,
exactly.
Right.
So,
so then the,
the nexus for political belief seems to
be openness so that that exploratory
tendency that you talked about
exploration of ideas and creativity and
low orderliness and so then I thought,
well why in the world would,
why would the political nexus go across
those dimensions,
which are some relatively uncorrelated.
Then I thought,
and this is in keeping with your work on
discussed,
is that it's an issue of borders,
which of course seems more or less self
evident in the wake of trump's election
when he talked about borders.
But you might say,
and I think this is reasonable,
that the conservative is someone who
wants the borders between categories to
remain intact no matter what level of
analysis,
so it's borders from the highest
resolution level of cognition all the
way up to the actual physical borders
of,
of rooms,
towns,
states,
countries,
all of that.
So the borders should be thicker and the
reason they want that.
Now,
there was a paper published in Plos one,
I don't know if you saw it,
it was a couple of years ago.
It was a mind boggling paper.
It should have been front page news as
far as I was concerned.
And what the researchers did was between
countries and then within provinces or
states within countries,
they correlated the level of,
um,
of frequency of infectious disease with
authoritarian political beliefs and
found a walloping correlation.
It was like point,
it was one of the highest by the,
for,
for those of you who don't know,
social scientists never discover
anything that's associated with anything
else at a correlation of point six other
than heritability other than
heritability.
Yes.
And so what they found was that the
higher the prevalence of infectious
disease,
the higher the probability of,
of totalitarian authoritarian political
attitudes,
and then they controlled for governance
because one of the questions was,
was this pop down authoritarianism or
bottom up authoritarianism?
And the answer was that it was bottom
up.
Okay.
And so I thought about that in two from
two perspectives simultaneously at the
time.
Okay.
So we identified disgust,
sensitivity with orderliness,
so say a fundamental sub trait.
Then I was reading this book that was
called Hitler's table talk,
and it was a,
it was the recordings of virtually
everything he said at dinner from 1939
to 1942.
Yeah.
So it's a spontaneous utterance say,
and it's full of discussions about Jews
and Gypsies and all the people he
tormented.
But what's really interesting is all the
language is discussed.
It's not feared.
So,
so Hitler is basic metaphor was that the
area,
race and country was a pure body.
And then it was assaulted by parasites,
right?
And then I remembered what happened to
the native Americans when the Europeans
showed up and shook hands.
What happened was that 95 percent of
them are dead within 50 years,
right?
Because of smallpox and measles,
and so that that border issue that
separates conservatives from liberals,
let's say,
is the conservative say the novel is
potentially contaminated.
It's not so much that it's dangerous.
That's different.
That's fear.
It's contaminated.
And the Liberals say,
hold on a minute.
If you make the borders too thick,
then information can't pass through.
Exactly.
So that's the Omnivore's dilemma right
there.
Right?
And,
and then since we have a biological
architecture on which are cognitive
platforms are erected,
we have the same attitude towards
abstract information,
which would be ideas that we do to
things like food or,
or illness.
Right?
Right.
And so we can think of an invading idea
or a polluting idea or contaminating
idea.
Yeah,
that's right.
Now I'm a big fan of George lakoff
metaphors.
We live by that.
We yet we use our bodily,
our bodily Schema data to think about
abstract things like politics and like
what our policies should be about
borders and immigration.
Uh,
there's a Canadian psychologist,
mark shaller.
He and his colleagues have developed
what they call an account over these,
the behavioral immune system,
right.
That we don't just try to,
you know,
microbes killed probably many more of
our ancestors.
Dan Did Lions and tigers and bears and
so whoever can keep themselves and their
children from being exposed to fatal
illnesses,
winds the evolutionary game.
And so a lot of that is judging
carefully about people.
Is he dangerous,
dangerous.
And that's both for sexuality,
for contact,
for all kinds of association.
Um,
so yeah,
and a lot of ways our emotions and
bodily interactions structure,
how we think and feel about about
social.
Well even with the black death in
Europe,
I mean,
so the black death occurred in Europe
when the Europeans started to move
around the world and they brought back
rats that were infected.
Exactly.
So,
so what you saw there was both of those
forces at work at the same time.
So the European expansion produced a
tremendous interchange of ideas from all
around the world.
That's globalization,
but it wiped out somewhere between 30
and 60 percent of the population at the
same time.
So wouldn't it
be good if in every society or every
organization,
and we had some people who specialized
in a specialized insane,
hey,
what are the opportunities?
And then we had other people who
specialize in saying,
well,
but what are the risks?
And it just so happens that a lot of
people have trouble doing all that in
themselves.
When we have systems that are well
constituted with people who have
different personalities and different
motives and goals,
we actually can get better outcomes.
We can have a discussion between them.